two stories that we've been covering
sort of come together in one story in
that a trump supporter was caught
screaming effing Jews at a protest meant
to protest the counting of all of the
ballots in Florida so we've got Story
number one which is the emboldened and
sort of coalescing of the most
disgusting radical extreme elements of
the right this includes white
nationalists this includes anti-semites
and they have been catalyzed and
activated by the presidency of Donald
Trump that's Story number one the second
story is that of the attacks on our
democracy and specifically the attacks
on voting that are coming from the right
this includes voter suppression this
includes gerrymandering the entire thing
we've been talking about but recently it
also includes doing everything possible
to stop the recount from actually
happening in Florida after a ton of
ballots were found uncounted at a mail
handling facility so now we combine the
two stories and what we end up with are
the vile extremists that have been
activated by Trump protesting in Florida
to stop the recount and prevent all of
the ballots that have been cast from
actually being counted and at that
protest there was a trump supporting
woman who was heard yelling effing Jews
her name is reportedly MJ she started
yelling the effing Jews this caused a
crowd to kind of gather around her and
then she said oh no I am Jewish I'm just
angry that in South Florida which has a
lot of Jews the Jews are voting for
Democrats instead of for Republicans MJ
apparently wants Jews in Florida and I
would guess choose all over to vote for
Republicans instead of for Democrats and
of course oh no no no this can't
possibly be nobody can be anti-semitic
and Trump can't be fomenting
anti-semitism if MJ is Jewish and Trump
has a Jewish son-in-law and Jared
Kushner she just wants the Jews to stop
being so jewy and
are voting for Republicans which by the
way is just not gonna happen in any
great numbers understand the scene at
this protest which is a protest against
counting votes okay so if I without
knowing anything about the people there
Pat if I just tell you people are
protesting against the counting of votes
you're probably going to have the
impression that the people there are not
exactly going to be the best as Donald
Trump likes to say I don't even think it
would be commoners protesting the
recounts and counting all the votes I
think it would be like Republican
staffers right and this is just a
political hit job so you have the effing
Jews woman who starts yelling an NBC
report says that then a tattooed head
shaved guy with a cut-off shirt that had
a drawing of Trump riding a Harley while
holding a shotgun and the slogan drained
the swamp on it steps up next to f'ing
Jews woman and says quote they control
the media they control the entertainment
business and that's what they do
Donald Trump has done more for the Jews
and Israel than anybody before and it
doesn't matter and then another guy
named art Manon takes sort of center
stage and says he's more afraid of
liberals than terrorists who he fought
while serving in Iraq beautiful group of
people just absolutely lovely and it is
really scary how the anti-semitism has
exploded and and been almost coddled by
Donald Trump fine people on both sides
of a neo-nazi rally in Charlottesville
Virginia I'm a nationalist America first
all of this stuff and this may be a
topic more for the bonus show I don't
know that it's for totally public
consumption but I've actually been in
touch quite a bit recently with the
Boston anti-defamation league as well as
the Boston FBI related specifically to
issues of I guess I'll say emboldened
anti-semitism lately and if anything
we've been understating the depths of
the problem on the program even though
we talk about it pretty regularly we are
talking about it as if it is not quite
as serious as it actually is
and if you were to talk to the ADL and
FBI people on the ground right now you
might get a better understanding of
exactly how serious this is
we have a great program for you today we
were going to hear about the latest from
Kellyanne Conway we are going to have a
great interview I've got a fantastic
suggestion that comes to us today in the
form of a voicemail the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show
I am on Twitter at Dee Pakman I invite
you I would even say I implore you to
follow both of us on Twitter quick break
back after this today's program is
sponsored in part by Blink accom slash
Pakman if you've not already heard about
blink Asst it's amazing it's an app for
your phone tablet or web browser and
what they do is they take nonfiction
books popular nonfiction critically
acclaimed nonfiction
they condense the book into a fifteen
minute audio book you get all the most
important information and insights from
each book but you can soak up the entire
essence of the book in one sitting I've
listened to a ton of books on blinkin
recent one is a Robert Rice's new book
the common good also bunk by Kevin Young
useful in preparing me for the
pseudo-science miniseries that we're
producing and if you are a david pakman
show viewer or listener you can get a
seven day free trial by going to blink
accom slash Pakman if you're watching on
youtube use the link in the video
description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK is t.com
/pa ke ma n